hey guys it's Gary Vee on a Monday
morning still feeling the effects of an
incredible episode 4 of trash talk if
you haven't been following along we're
back after a long hiatus Josh you're
confused my friends I'm a winner you
root for winners dick trash talk is a
show where I go and turn trash into cash
[Music]
trash talk episode four wait okay now
from the beginning
[Music]
I mean there's so many things going on
here I see all sorts of action I want to
I want to pee high with it I want a
piece of action to do the mob better
action box I'm just gonna gonna randomly
go into people's homes
hey Instagram I'm in somebody's house
randomly my first sale today this is my
country this is my country first two
sales garbage
[Music]
I don't see what's going on here
$5.00 something up there I thought she
was a little bit unfair with the dollar
off there if I wanted the mug but she
was like mean-mugging me actually
trash-talker episode 4 bang I see it and
I'm feeling hot show this woman's got no
chance this lady's got no chance do any
sports cards or video games okay
that's devastating d-roc let's try
something can you hear me shake your
head amazing this is gonna be the new
part of trash talk invention episode 4
can you have little Lou look up UNICEF
mugs uni CEF fee look there's something
here that I'm not understanding this was
cute a [ __ ] it's cute s so cute a
squirrel
I'm gonna take these two mugs thank you
darling thank you have a great day
you took feeling really good about
myself and that mug life you know how we
live it mug likes [ __ ] mug life
it's very girly I'm panicking over for
making something happen here good
morning I'm good thanks [ __ ] beyond
frustrating first half an hour of
trash-talking so for disastrous but this
is where you gotta be patient kids you
got a patient for the life I need a
patient's and garage-sale Isis I will
say I'm easily more patient in life than
I am in garage sale I'm already
panicking get hot please get hot you
don't have any video games do you like
Nintendo games or I saw I saw the Guitar
Hero thing not that directly see you
good news we got action vs games and the
good stuff sonic sonic Sheldon Wow sonic
Pokemon Sonic let's go alright huge hit
I paid 10 bucks for five DS games we are
looking them up right now boom right off
the bat 40 bucks for this Zelda 25 for
this Sonic let's go to the next one but
come on let's go no I got the ones that
were right I know how to by little
little by I passed on the games that
aren't worth as much did I can't
we're not speller slow we're not
spellers were sellers [ __ ]
let's go Lou what you didn't see cuz I
sat on my mic was that she wanted five
bucks apiece and I negotiated down to
two so from 25 to 10 and then 100 plus
come up negotiations its key
hey sis just destroyed it just paid ten
bucks for five DS games at least at
least a hundred and twenty five bucks
profit yeah it's it's all it's all out
here and like people are complaining you
know I love you I got six check my
Instagram story I'm killing it oh close
like it's my job yeah this guy's taking
a guitar look at him he's stealing that
guitar that guy right there stealing
that guitar he's playing her into a coma
he's tricking her into a coma
VHS is such an interesting to be
better-looking hear me gremlins original
gremlins 1985 yep
yes really
Jesus Christ I'm about to buy a [ __ ]
load of VHS tapes boy I don't want to do
this and I can feel it's happening
I'll tell you don't know where you live
Teaneck library yep
where we're having a book sale and
people donate they just have to be
giving away you can come and say okay
thank you
that lady flex on the other lady she's
like don't buy these
we got a library full of VHS is for free
well how would she do that cuz she's a
gangster no she's not she's a hater
I got no pixels like not on my hip you
get clicked if you remake the box and
dicin you a shot of some bleep we gonna
make you go viral you sound like Tyrese
you see my name on a single my [ __ ]
gonna mean you will be at show album
release pick me up beaches gather my g3
Matt come on Paul said he got on some
free liquor Jordans but I'm not buying
that [ __ ] face and sneakers just me
always going through yellows is king
never stop at yellow that's difference
between an entrepreneur and employee
never never you've got more time than
you think gutter just hold the bucket we
got two sticks on us and probably the
audio went out so the audio went out
what I was just saying was we just
bought entire box of nerf guns for 20
bucks that's pretty nasty an amazing
deal
what do you think yeah I feel better
already
really yeah seriously which is huge [ __ ]
yeah
Instagram you're not gonna believe this
just bought a massive amount of nerf
guns like ridiculous and now little do I
need you start looking these up while I
go this next sale I think these are just
absurd all right guys we're often that
now we're starting to get somewhere
right we're doing you filming well we're
getting somewhere now what's cool is
this car this might be a really good
deal I have to do some with that good
bro how are you know uh worried about
the look of this I love whales luckily
your swag [ __ ]
is the car for sale nuts yeah thank you
66 Mustang it's [ __ ] fresh it's on top
of a truck rate to 60
and chevy blazer creams so it's a 4x4
but with the Mustang top you roll with
it
I once in a while you know and my dad
lets it out when you want to flex all
right that was a devastating garage sale
however meanwhile back at the trunk
little Lou is looking up the nerf guns
and I'm feeling really good about this
you might not know how to do it but I'm
feeling great about it
Lou what's that just these 3 is 33 bucks
how much is this one
how much is this one alright so like
bring this out I mean the bow and arrow
how did you not look up the bullet let
me guess
how did you not look this up yet I mean
this [ __ ] thing is a flexor this is
25 it's only one of them 30 guns that we
bought ok 20 you made that money back on
the first guy that's what that's the
first all right you already the money
back yeah well you know fees and all
that let's keep this honest but net net
this 20 is easy you're gonna be it's
gonna be 200 it just is that looks like
garbage but we'll try
[ __ ] what about this one
surprise you might have dear oh yeah
he's right he's right good [ __ ] Luke
this is episode Ford who knows I saw the
iMac guys map one Gary zero like put up
the [ __ ] icon put it up map one Gary
zero maps to live it's a possible oh I
am holy [ __ ] excuse me how much is the
Jets code the Jets code so [ __ ] cool
[ __ ] I love this coat [ __ ] I love this
coat how much I hate to insult it's a
big difference between where you're at
and we're on that what's that blood 10ft
would you turn
it's got a nice day huh
cards
Bobby every card that was ever made
brother I got so much of this [ __ ] it's
crazy how it worked out you know it felt
so good at the time but it didn't yeah
yeah that's right you want to do ten on
the jacket uh lieutenant I appreciate
that that's awesome thank you you have a
ten oh yeah thank you
how much are the video games fine
would you do uh would you do these 310
so I just give you the 20
thank you guys thank have a wonderful
day you too take care of yourself
holy [ __ ] thanks so much holy [ __ ] no
audio you got audio did you not have it
did you have it the whole time
holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
let's get somewhere cuz something
amazing just happened here holy [ __ ]
low do you see what you're holding in
your hand do you know how much that is
worth I cannot believe what just
happened - no not the [ __ ] coat the
Zelda games let's go let's go I'm fine
I'm faster I'm far enough let's go
this is huge this is monumental let's
get into a nice place and record this
post game holy [ __ ] we hit big [ __ ]
Big D Rock and he rocks the audio work
the whole time there's a huge score I'm
super fired up here we go so first
you're gonna see that I negotiated heavy
alright we're gonna see first is I
scored a massive Jets retro jacket he
wanted 25 he didn't get it he didn't get
it and then he wanted 15 and he didn't
get that either baby 10 bucks from jets
vintage I'm gonna wear myself that's not
even go for sale all right let's just
let's just nail this down pay 3 33 for
each cuz I got these 3 for 10 you'll see
the whole thing I paid 20 for the Jets
jacket and the three links and [ __ ]
the links are let's call 50/25/25 so 100
just for those that's Jets jacket if
that wasn't hanging out there I wouldn't
have stopped I would have never gotten a
Zelda that's why you always have a man
guys never listen to your intuition oh
we see it through
I should have trusted my Caleb we gotta
use that I should've followed my gut on
the last other places follow your gut
kids never just go on intuition see it
all the way through it's why the answer
is always both never listen to yourself
I mean this got no shot or oh there are
stuffed animals here we go oh [ __ ] this
guy's got a peach picks out this lady's
trying to take all my [ __ ] how much
should of stuffed animals
the big ones are a dollar and the small
ones are three for a dollar thank you to
the Yankees for a dollar I'll do that
[ __ ] all right
three dollars I didn't want to do this
it seems like this goes with these two
right all right yep got it two three
yeah lost mark you got a bag thank you
this I like d-roc thank you so much
welcome the guy back there he was
wearing a Patriots hat so I had a
[ __ ] rip his [ __ ] face off for all
my pent-up anger about football now
let's look up these Yankee bears which I
got three for a dollar let's see what
they're worth and this cute little husky
with this little baby and a little black
dog when it's baby let's look it up bang
1999 good with Mike here we go continue
the hot streak hello all right we were
hot I mean there was no way I could be
upset about that see what happens here
have a great day guys take care thank
you here we go
$4 tyre this one has potential hello I'm
super well how are you guys what's up
bruh how you doing okay man that's crazy
I was watching this watching your videos
nice to meet you Brad sure will
oh well hey they good here I'm not sure
I'm trying to figure it out garage son
ya hit doing that thing you doing well
yeah give me that thanks for love thank
you bro get out of here so I can do my
thing yes keep going you get out of here
and I can do my thing how much is this
poster 5
[Music]
would you would you do three cool I
can't believe I'm [ __ ] buying this
thing I just can't let it go it's
probably worth a hundred son of a [ __ ]
I'm so pissed right now I don't want to
touch it
Lu can you come here and get it oh boy I
didn't want to grab it but I had to get
it
business is business there's a chance
that the poster I just bought is $220 I
think that's it I just have a feeling
you rock film this whole thing we passed
the garage sale I wasn't gonna turn
around and then I just let my feelings
take over so that's the Yui this could
be huge or it can be a waste for minutes
and that is also huge this is huge it's
on Helen app it's a dead end
you get it you rock Helen ABS dead end
here we go awkward looks if all sorts of
things happen here devastating I'm damn
it
like look at trash truck episode 4 I've
heard it like I've read the comments
like people like oh what about the fuel
what about the email eBay fees what
about the shipping what about it like
fuel costs money every business cost
money it costs you fuel to go to work to
you put like everything costs money
right shipping charge them shipping
incorporate that into your costs or add
$5 shipping add $20 shipping floor
raising by 5 bucks like shipping his
business took a little break got a
little snacks got everybody settled now
I need action
I need three elections
be jerky protein [ __ ]
ghostwriter legit awesome have we're
good day guys
take care thank you used to stay well
take care high five from the guy was
amazing
you gotta do something funny like going
to bushes just going through the bush
from far away well this one was too
obvious but I really think there's gonna
be a scenario where you're gonna be able
to do go into the bushes like it would
just be funny content like you're in the
bushes like right some people I just
love this this is gonna be it you don't
have any video games do you cutest
couple today for sure to these peeps
this lady was the best person I've seen
the whole time the best lady was amazing
she was like a hundred and not give a
[ __ ] she's negotiating follow the yellow
brick road follow the yellow brick road
I feel like I'm Dorothy exactly like but
I'm not sure but Lou is definitely
reliable I'm the one the lion there's
stuff going on already no come with me
on this one
this is not [ __ ] enough to be what we
wanted all right let's go
couple thumbs down double thumbs down
the same people who are complaining
about what about your fuel are the ones
that are literally driving to work for a
$12 an hour job or just going out well I
don't want to talk about their $4
Rolling Rock people talking [ __ ] they
don't have money in volume [ __ ] 3
rolling right buying a $15.00 cocktail
like I'm complaining about your boss and
your job that's fine but driving around
and spending that same 15 dollars on
fuel all day hustling from 7:00 a.m. to
12:00 on a Saturday to make 300 bucks
that you got to leave the [ __ ]
comment okay Johnny pants 63 I feel you
you're really scaring me off I'm not
standing behind the tree in their free
yard catch it let's just make some funny
contact
[Music]
good bro how are you how's it been going
it's nice day they see you d-roc
let's go back in this is rad I know we
still have this exactly cuz it's not fun
to play with your show but just get a
couple of beers going right they gave
that well they're running over the place
you know their movement you know your
guys in the corner I'm like this this is
taking forever
how's the sale been good sorry yeah at
least you got a nice day yeah that's for
sure the Lord of the Rings goblets take
care guys stay well thank you so much
bro
Lisa made a best friend
[Music]
here's the point you're just seeing what
I want to selectively pick up the
reality of be really really really like
if I really needed to make money I would
have a shitty truck right now that
doesn't guzzle gas and I would I would
have made five hundred to a thousand
already because I would just want
everything this guy's played chicken
with me he lost he lost
Punk'd I was the aggressor these guys
look like my competition yeah I got oh
he just got something what'd he get
thank you I think he knows who I am -
that's are you he's making his own thing
what's going on I'm well you good
how are you got a good score [ __ ] yeah
let's go it's a breathless Gary house
they be going good okay
[Applause]
[Music]
so awesome man have a good time yeah
take care kind of watch out for the fans
we need the poos always in play thank
you coming up
it's not what I thought it was going god
damn it
those he-man books were legit I really
thought it was gonna be awesome
how are we not finding bugs Wow just
know I mean we're finding the Nintendo
games in package vintage jets but we're
not finding bugs
d-roc right now is hitting up the rest
of team Gary to try to make this right
yep I see the action now what hey nobody
come attorneys
the nice
whoa
she knows too much
My Little Ponies what would you what
would you do for all the ponies how many
didn't count and Counting about 34 they
might have miscounted if I lost some of
the little ones I might call my sister
they said thank you do you want My
Little Ponies I'll send you a picture
you hearing all this Jesus
hello I'm gonna I just sent you the
pictures sixty sixty right ma'am ma'am
sixty
yeah do you want them
I love talking to myself at a garage
sale yeah
trash talk episode 4 trying to make the
score that really matters yell ask her
would you consider doing 40
I'll take them
[Applause]
I was already discounting why
[Applause]
I know
I got the green light for 40
[Applause]
you go 44 I hope you guys heard me
because I know the sound went out when I
came back and went on speaker but we
ended up settling that the over 50 she
wanted three bucks apiece I go what do
you want for all of it to try to context
that she counts 34 which gets due to a
hundo she comes in with 60 look what I'm
doing here what's going on I'm going
through some sort of store around I'm at
Starbucks I'm at the Container Store how
the [ __ ] did I end up at the Container
Store like reset on me just turn around
can I do something weird to get out of
here no you're good okay all right she
wanted a hundo she came in at 60 with
the discount so already we're in a good
spot
we're down to two bucks a pop you know a
little bit less right off the bat
sometimes what I want to pay something I
wanted to pay 40 I'll go like 30 leave
myself room to negotiate other times
I'll go in for it too quick so I went 40
boom that this time it didn't work then
I went with the awkward 44 to see what I
could do with it and then she just was
emotional about him she said we should
go 50 just such a good deal for 30 you
know for 34 original My Little Ponies
for 50 bucks wait to see what these go
for individually it's pretty gnarly I'm
talking about yeah here
I'm gonna call my sister I love talking
to myself at a garage sale
yeah you know sometimes I'm trying to
build some narratives out there on the
right side filling some narratives out
there that might help me with my
negotiation guys we hit it hard
original My Little Ponies 34 of them
little though show it show it 34
original ponies original My Little
Ponies early eighties like it's our job
wait you see what these things go for
she wanted a hundred she didn't get it
she wanted 60 she didn't get it she got
50
all right we're headed to the last sale
of the day 12:37 a.m. start at 9:00
three and a half hours did a ton of
damage I mean stuff that I haven't been
finding for a long time I just flip
ponies like crazy My Little Ponies was a
big part of my early days of garage
saleing found them Nintendo big part
found them mention vintage jacket this
I'm gonna wear this all the time crushed
on the nerf guns kind of rip off that
Patriot fan like this was a very
accomplished day I see it Thank You Luke
gonna angle Road Kurt Angle spelled
differently
[Music]
whoo good way to end looks like a big
stack let's see if we can score no I
don't know maybe it might be nice for to
wrap it up I did get any mugs just
disappointment got like 1 to begin
actually nothing's at the beginning of
it
how much are the bugs so now we found
like so pumped milk - milk mugs milk
mugs the clapper
would you do a $1 for three please
there's nothing that excites me more
than 1980s girls toys memorabilia picked
up this Strawberry Shortcake mug for 33
cents roll down the window d-roc respect
the game strawberry shortcake milk mug
what mom and dad milk mug mama Papa yo
first we picked up the ponies then we
got strawberry shortcake
it's 1980s girl life up in here plus a
mama and a daddy milk bug milk mugs he's
kind of like cloudy milk mugs our beast
it was three dollars for those three
there was no ax to holler for three
we get it out here got this red light
blue tell him I just
cuz I'm quick like that I guess sir I
miss tanks for old school
how we doing did we hit it we did really
good
[Applause]
all right guys episode 4 of trash talk
in the books crushed it let's go through
the recap had a great day four hours of
driving $25 in gas yes they pay shipping
let's get into I paid 10 bucks for this
jacket it's priceless
picked up this playboy poker set for a
buck it's 11 it's got a huge bag of
ponies 34 of them for 50 bucks about a
buck 33 a pop when it's all broken down
based on what I'm seeing I'm gonna
arrange this at 125 to 175 bucks pick up
this vintage Disney book it's banged up
a little bit
pick it up for three let's go 20 got
this build-a-bear husky with the little
baby in the mouth paid a buck rip that
Patriot fan off that goes for 19 that
same Pats fan I took these Yankee teddy
bears three of them let's go ten on that
and here's the third one
and the other black his babies let's go
ten on that so 20 they're picked up
these three Adventures of link Nintendo
games one in box meant to clean mint
games mint I'm gonna go with the 35
actually a piece of these are 80
I think it's 70 and 30 130 this is 150
paid 10 bucks for all 3 333 apiece 150
on the flip classic vintage Nintendo I
paid 10 for these four epic CS games
they'll go for a bucket a quarter paid a
dollar
33 cents a pop and a strawberry
shortcake and mom and dad milk mugs milk
mugs are these creamy kind of ceramic
thing 2015 35 on the flip picked up this
Michael Jordan thing poster vintage $3
50 to 200 bucks
this is real early in the morning
applying petard to New York and I just
got this $175 offer
scored an insane amount of nerf guns p24
um I think you're looking at at least I
mean what do you think little achieve
under it maybe 250 250 at least maybe
300 this is a massive score looking at
250 to 300 on the flip just nerf going
four days on the flip
[Music]
[Music]